[Music]
okay everybody I am really excited today
because I am joined by Wally lamb the
author of the book I know this much is
true and he is also the executive
producer of the show I know this much is
true how are you doing today Wally I am
good how are you mr. barley I'm doing
good man so I'm really excited to talk
to you I think you're such a brilliant
writer and it's showing also and how
good this show is and it almost sets the
ceiling up for the show to be sky-high
and it's interesting because I wonder
when were you first approached about
this novel coming to the screen and did
you have any fears or hesitation about
actually having that happen yeah good
question
the novel was published in 1998 and it's
sold to the movies right out of the box
it was the same month of publication the
plan was to make it into a feature film
so somewhere around two hours or so
now the the complication there was that
there's a 900-page book that they were
going to try to jam into two hours and
obviously there's going to be a lot that
would have to be cut and I was you know
I was fine for them to try to do that
but the studio hired a couple of I think
maybe three different screenwriters at
different points they could never fit
this giant story into a into a two-hour
box if you will so 15 years go by and I
get a call I think this was 2014 I got a
call from my agent and she said do you
remember that little thing we put in the
contract about how if they didn't make a
movie within 15 years the rights would
revert back to you and I had to confess
that I had probably never read that
contract anyway what had happened in
most 15 years is that along came you
know some of the premium series that
we're starting to be done you know by
HBO and you know and other others and
you know with terrific
actors and so forth so anyway my agent
said she was going to try to shop it
around and see if anybody was interested
in a series and she said who would be
your first choice to play the twins and
I said oh that you know that's easy Mark
Ruffalo
so she had a connection to Mark through
her agency he at the time he was he was
filming a movie in Europe and so she
sent him the book and about maybe a week
later he got back to her and she shared
me she shared with me the email that he
had sent and it was one of the most
exciting things I had forgotten
indirectly and he said basically he
loved the book he's sorry he was only
half half done with it his slow reader
and he had to learn lines and all that
kind of stuff but you know there was
there was nothing pre-madonna
about this you know this reaction to it
and he said I would I really want to do
this I know already that I really want
to do this because I know these people
you know these these were the people
that I grew up with you know
working-class you know he's half Italian
half Italian so he was good for his word
we did meet when he finished filming in
Europe and we hit it off and then we
spent next couple of years sort of
looking for the right director and and
then we found in Derek's in France see
that's really awesome because hearing
that makes me so happy because when you
see someone's an executive producer
sometimes you're like well are they just
stamping their name on it or they
actually involved in to hear that you're
so involved with this coming about as a
show is really cool can you just like
elaborate a little more than that to
like you're saying Derek C and France
came in were you there pretty much the
whole way through when they were casting
certain characters and writers now what
happened was it you know I remember it
was marks idea to take a you know a
really serious look at Derek and I had
seen Derek's a couple of his films and
really loved him
one was Blue Valentine and the other was
the place beyond the pines and you know
but they're you know they were small
independent movies but you know then we
had this big straw
thing that we try to do but Derek and
Mark and I had a had a lunch in lower
Manhattan and I liked him immediately
and you know at that point he had read
the novel and he really wanted to do it
he thought he could do you know a good
job with it and he originally had sort
of mapped out several more episodes than
just the six that it finally came down
to but you know he just seemed to have
really good instincts about it and he
said to me and he said this many times
when he was writing the episodes he says
don't worry I am going to honor your
book I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm going to
honor what the book means and I said to
him okay yeah that's you know that's
good I'm glad but I said I don't want
you to honor it so much that you don't
make it your own and he you know died
thinking he said as much that that sort
of freed him from you know to sort of go
where he wanted to go with this material
but still being you know respectful of
the material I trusted Derek and I
certainly trusted mark because you know
he was executive producing too and so I
let it go at that point
I didn't want to read you know the the
scripts for each of the episodes I
wanted them to you know sort of not
having me hover over them so I guess
probably other than being a consultant
here and there
my executive producing had to do with
the sort of the preliminary stuff you
know finding the right the right
production company and finding the right
director and you know I had to I had a
little bit of a say in the in some of
the character you know some of the
casting and so forth but I would say
that once the shooting started once the
you know the filming began my biggest
you know thing was just visiting the set
and getting to know people and kind of
eating lunch with with the crew as well
as the cast and that kind of thing so I
like to say that the fact that I was an
executive producer kinda meant that I
could ride in the car with the cool kids
I had to
just shut my mouth and not say anything
that's great yeah that's like the
perfect answer for someone to ask you
what do you do is executive reducer on
the show that just puts it in a nutshell
no but that's interesting too so sitting
there as you see the final product of
the show and you're seeing all these
characters that came from your
imagination like you're the only one who
can give us this answer but when you
watch the final product is it thrilling
is it nerve-racking are you like are you
scared like are these characters sacred
to you that oh maybe this won't come out
how I imagined or what is like your
mindset even watching it I was thrilled
I watched a nearly final cut of each
episode with my wife we went down in New
York and you know we were invited to it
like a screening room and we it was a
Monday morning we watched the first
three episodes and then we went back
into the city the following Monday to
watch episodes four five and six I would
say between my wife and and me we sort
of destroyed a box a whole box of
Kleenex because and luckily there was
one there in the room because it was
very emotional to me I didn't observe
any false notes I didn't particularly
care you know that's that some stuff was
pared down or some stuff was added I
just wanted it to be a really good film
and so I was you know I was with so I
felt pleased and honored that you know
that they had worked so hard to make
that happen and when I say they I
certainly mean mark and Derek but also
you know the entire cast and crew yeah
they were you know I don't I don't have
a lot of experience visiting you know
film sets but I was really pleased with
you know how smooth and professional
everything was you know and I made I
think four different trips up took the
kit see when they were when they were
filming and I never noticed any prima
donna stuff and people were welcoming
and you know happy that you know that I
had come to visit and you know they were
you could tell that people really cared
this project it wasn't just a job they
really wanted to deliver the best I
think I don't know but I think that's
probably fairly unusual for a sir I
don't know that you see the passion
right on the screen to that everyone's
giving 150% now for people who don't
know this isn't your first rodeo
executive producing as in 2014 one of
your novels the executive produced
wishing and hoping I was wondering as I
think why people want to know this is
there any other novels of yours that you
would like to see translated to TV or
film oh sure yeah there are my first
novel was called she's come undone and
as far as I know it still was called
that it was it that came out in 1992 and
Oprah sort of made of the household name
in 1997 when she picked it for her book
club and that had that has been a film
project for for as long as the novel has
existed so you know whatever
how many reverie however many years has
been since 1992 I don't know I can't do
the math it would be 27 because I was
born in 92 so I was I was a baby oh my
god yeah okay well I was that with you
but anyway that was a you know a film
project for Warner Brothers forever and
then it kind of went into development
hell and and so far it stayed there but
I think it's still a very you know it
could be a viable story you know with
the right with the right person and the
right screenwriter and director and so
forth people came and went
Zack Graff and Reese Witherspoon and you
know several others you know we're
interested in the project but then
nothing ever came of it so I'd love to
see that in film and my later novel we
our water is sort of in a development
stage it's you know it hasn't gotten
green lip or anything but you know we're
we're sort of you know preparing that to
go to market well I'll tell you this
while after people watch this show I
feel like everyone's me knocking
your door calling your phone you're
gonna be a next Stephen King with all
these big projects and the name on these
movies which is so cool and awesome and
I really appreciate you taking the time
today to talk to me everyone please
watch I know this much is true on HBO
Sunday nights at 9:00 p.m. and you can
also catch it on demand Wally have a
great day please you and your family
stay safe during all this madness and I
hope to talk again soon
this was fun Steve thank you appreciate
it bye